硬くないという で 心は硬くなったら何もできないんですね
で いつでもこの柔軟性あると
まあ物事うまくできます
ここはあまり説明しなくたっても
カッマンニャタ カッマンニャタですね
次にカッマンニャタというカーエ
チッタ両方あります カーエ・カッマンニャタとチッタ・カッマンニャタ
2つ カーエ・カッマンニャタ
チッタ・カッマンニャタって 2つあります
カッマンニャタの日本語は適合性
で 適合性とか言ってますけど
カッマンニャタっていうのはこの serviceability
act activity
みたいな activeness
のような 日本語の言葉で言ったら
まあいわゆるこの適合性なんですけど
まあまあそれは意味がありますけどね
まだ言葉を見つけられないんです
他の言葉 で 心がこの次にやる仕事にも適しているんですね
まあ柔らかいし すぐ次の状況に変換できるような状態にあると
で 適合性あれば確実にそのやらなくちゃいけないことはちゃんとできるようになっているんですね
まあ繰り返し現象はいっぱいありますけど
まあしょうがないんですね
ちょっと待って 次にカーエ・パーグンニャタ
次の 2つはカーエ・パーグンニャタ
チッタ・パーグンニャタ
それの日本語は連達性
で これはどういう言葉から取っているかというと
このパーグンニャっていうのは何かをして
この経験がある というパーグンニャというサンスクリット語の言葉から出てくるんですけど
あの まあ訓練して 何か訓練する
練習すると 我々は心と体が何か変わっちゃうんですね
その変わっている状態
例えば勉強するということは
この心の訓練なんですね
そうすると その勉強した心は
それからどんな仕事にも適用できますね
何も勉強していない場合は
なかなか新しい仕事あってもできないんですね
まあとにかくこのパーグンニャ
この言葉っていうのは
あの 練習しているという意味なんです
練習済みという意味なんです
まあ現代の言葉で言えば
なんかプロみたいなもので
プロになっていると まあそれだったらもうプロになったってことは仕事ができるということなんですね
でも 心理学の世界では
これどういうふうな言葉でいいかどうか
ちょっと難しいんですけど
で この場合は大体この今
先進書だから 行進書だから
どうしても成功の世界のことを言ってるんです
成功する世界ですから
このいい世界 失敗しない世界のことを言ってるんですね
生きている場合は だから失敗しない
正しく何かやる場合は
我々はその辺はやる前にもなんとなくできるような状態があるんです
全然できるような状態がないと仕事できるわけじゃないんですね
じゃあ何か文章を書くことにしますと
じゃあこれから文章を書かなくちゃいけないと
それで立派な文章を書けたと思うならば
書ける前にもその人に書ける状態があったんです
書ける状態がなかったならば
書けるわけじゃないんだから
ですから 成功する前にこのパーグンユタはなければダメなんですね
できる状態 練習済み状態
訓練済み状態なければいけないんですね
これは心理的な状況だから
まあちょっとその辺で理解しにくいかもしれません
理解しにくいところは
日常生活のところから勉強すればいいんです
走る人は毎日走って走って練習する
そうすると競争で走れる状態はもう揃っている
体が軽い 行動的で もう大丈夫
ここでちゃんと音を聞いた瞬間にもう走れるんですね
そういうふうに物事を成功する場合は
成功する以前の適合性とこれは連達性はあると
次にあるのは単極性 単極性
ウッジュカタ カーヤウッジュカタ
カーヤウッジュカタと書くんだけど
パーリ語の場合はこっち母音こっち母音だから一つ落とさなくちゃいけないんです
ですからこの前のア落とすんです
落としてこれなくなったらウだからカーユッジュカタ
正しい言葉なんです でもわかりやすく僕はカヤと書きましたけども
この場合もこのア落としてチットゥッジュカタと書くんです
カーユッジュカタ チットゥッジュカタ
カーヤウッジュカタ チットゥッジュカタというと
まあ言葉分けてますけど
このテキストを見ると
このアを落としていることが見えると思います
これ母音 2つ 並べて書かないです
こっちアは母音でウは母音だから
とにかく ２つまとめて 1つにするか
1つ落とすか どっちかにしなくちゃいけない
落とす場合は大体アはかわいそうに落ちてしまうんです
なぜならば 落ちてもアは基本的な母音だから
もう発見しやすい ウを落としちゃったらあまり基本的な母音じゃないんだから発見しにくいんです
ですから 落とす場合はアがあるならばアは落ちる
他の母音だったら どっちが落とすかわからなくなっちゃいますから
2つまとめて違う母音にする
そうすると計算で知ってます
この母音はこれとこれ足したところでできていることだから
パーリ語 サンスクリット語を勉強する場合は
そういう訓練がいっぱいないと読めんでもわからないんです
言葉をすぐつなげてしまっちゃうんです
それは発音の問題で カーヤウッジュカタというと発音ちょっと難しいんです
大体節入れてパーリ語
サンスクリット語発音するんですよ
あまり喋る言葉ではないので
だからカーヤウッジュカタ
チットウッジュカタと発音はしにくいです
ししやすいんです カーヤウッジュカタ
チットウッジュカタ このアクセントちゃんと入れてやる場合は
カーヤウッジュカタとこちらにアクセント
チットウッジュカタとこちらにアクセント
アクセント入れるところでカーヤウッジュカタというとちょっと引っかかっちゃうんです
まあそこはまあこちらに関係ないんだけど
ウッジュカタっていうのは単直線
で あの心は あの 何て言いますか
柔軟性ムズターなんか言うと
柔軟性と硬い心で何もできない
じゃあ そうすると我々一般的に問題が出てくるんです
やっぱり何かやるならば
それをちゃんと決めて
心は固めてやるんではないかと
だからその それがそちらで言ってるんですよ
まっすぐと そのこちらのこの単直線っていうのは硬いっていうのじゃなくて
ちゃんとまっすぐっていう意味なんですね
だから決めた行動をすると
だから単直線と訳しているんです
一応それであの 興心祖の十九は終わりました
そこでわかるのは 宗教的な道徳としてそれほどない
でしょ？すごい基本的なことを言っている
宗教的と制定と言えるのはアローバとアドーサと心なんですね
なんか宗教臭いと言えるならば
でも定義ではそれも決して宗教臭いものではないんです
すごい心理学的なものなんです
そこでこの状況揃ったら
どんなものでも人は成功するんです
そこで成功するといったって大きな大観な言葉で
アビダンマではこの心理学的なものだから
認識の問題なんですよ
どんなものでもちゃんと認識すると
この仕事って言ったっても
それまた結局認識の世界だから
すべては認識だから 手を伸ばすっていうことは認識であって
それ認識から手を伸ばすんですから
正しく認識すると正しく手を伸ばす
間違った認識すると 手を伸ばしたことは間違ってるんですね
ですから 我々はこの仕事を仕事というのは体の動きでしょ
体は心がないと動かないんだから
心を動くためには その問題はちゃんと認識しておかなくちゃいけないし
ですから 正しく認識できれば
体の行動というのは正しい行いますよと
ですから わしはもう仕事を仕事と言っても
結局は認識の問題で 音は聞くと
音は聞くというのはアビダンマの世界で
我々のは授業は聞くとかね
人の話を聞くとか いろんな聞くことがあるかもしれませんだけど
でも仏教においては ただ何でも聞くだけの世界
聞くならば正しく聞こえる
まあそうすると問題ないでしょ
そこで授業は聞いてる場合は心に柔軟性があって
明るさがあって 周りの環境をちゃんと把握して
我々サティがあって そうするとちゃんと聞いてるならばもう理解してるんじゃないんですか
そうすると授業は成功しましたと
受講者がみんな成功しましたと
理解しましたという結果になります
それで心は混乱状態で硬い状態でだるい状態で授業を聞いてもだるい状態はここの場合は眠気の状態なんです
眠気ってすごいだるいでしょう？ですから眠気がある場合は暗い心
眠気がなく明るい時はいい心
善心処 ですから 仏教の善悪っていうのは
悪を行うと地獄に落ちますよと
善を行うと天国に生まれ変わりますよというふうな俗的な話ではないんです
悪を行うと あなたは失敗して不幸になりますよと
善を行うと成功して幸福になりますよという話なんです
そこは天国地獄ではなくて
今世においても同じことなんです
ですから 私は堂々というのは
この世の中で何か成功しましたという人がいるならば
そのことを成功するために使った心の状態は確実に善心処でなければいけないんだと
ですから それは宗教と関係なく
我々は善心処なんでしょうかと勉強すると
それを心の中に育てると
どんなことでも成功する
逃げる必要はなくなるんです
どんなことでも自分にはできる
できないことはなくなっちゃうんです
そのためには善心処は必要なんです
これは徳を積む 悪をしないようにするという基本的な道徳的な宗教道徳的な話とはちょっとレベルが違うんです
これは基本的な心の世界のことを言ってるんです
道徳もまたかえって同じことなんです
だから仏教の道徳はあくまでも普遍性を持ってるんです
嘘を言うなというのは
仏教徒だから嘘言ってはいけないということではないんです
誰も嘘を言ったらひどい目に遭います
仏教で酒飲むなと言ってますけど
みんないろんな言い訳をして
大乗仏教では酒飲んでは構いませんとかね
キリスト教ですから酒飲んでも構いませんとかね
そんな話はないんです
酒飲むなというのは 酒飲んだ人は堕落するんだと
それはもう決まってるんです
それはキリスト教かイスラム教か仏教か大乗仏教か
それ関係ない 無神教か
どっちでも関係ない 欲張るなとか
ですから 仏教の道徳はある
特別な仏教という宗教の世界の道徳ではないんです
他の宗教をなんか勉強すると
その宗教に限る道徳はあるんですね
普遍性はない 釈尊がおっしゃった道徳は
その普遍性ある道徳なんです
例えばサティは仏教を信じてヴィパッサナー瞑想をやって悟りたいと思っている人だけのことかというと
そうじゃないんです サティがないと何一つうまくできないんです
誰でも人生を成功したければ
その 19種類の心相を育てなければ
すぐ育てられます 簡単に育てられます
いつでももっとわかりやすく言えば
いつでも明るく行動的にいればいいのです
いろいろ文句言ったりとかね
あれに文句を これに文句をとかね
そういう暗い性格を捨てて
物事の明るい側面を見て行動的でいればいいのです
いつも嫌だ嫌だという性格あるでしょう
それをやめれば で それが道だと思います
時間が飛びましたけど
では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました